a surge in demand for passports is
causing major delays at processing
centers a standard passport renewal
listen to this can now take up to 13
weeks and even expedited service is
taking up to nine weeks it's a long time
Chris Van Cleave shows us how this
backlog is causing big time travel
anxiety
UNC sophomore Kylie Parker thought she
was ahead of the game applying for a new
expedited passport months in advance of
her summer study abroad program it's
just been a mess ever since I spent
eight hours a day on the phone with the
passport line the other day we're
getting no calls through no calls back
and I'm just very scared of missing my
study abroad travel she's supposed to
leave North Carolina Sunday for Portugal
and Italy but still no passport it's
caught up in a growing backlog of
applications that now has her trip in
Jeopardy they said the only in-person
appointments would be that day in New
Hampshire the next morning at 10 A.M in
Minneapolis or the day I'm supposed to
leave for Europe in Seattle Washington
current wait times are as long as 13
weeks that's more than three months
oh it's prompting long lines at passport
offices across the country ahead of
what's expected to be a record-breaking
summer travel season they said the only
other option was to go to another
location which is in LA
I'm not going to go to La the state
department issued nearly 22 million
passports last year a record high
current demand is up at least 30 percent
as 500 000 applications a week keep
rolling in despite an increase in
funding and more staff wait times
continue to grow that we're really
digging in on this we were authorizing
overtime we've opened satellite offices
airline industry analyst Henry hartevelt
it's not just alarming it's embarrassing
I know people have been waiting three
four months to get their passports
fulfilled I haven't really been sleeping
I've been waking up nauseous I'm so
nervous
Parker's just hoping this passport
problem doesn't postpone her summer
semester in Europe for CBS mornings I'm
Chris Van Cleave in Los Angeles
well at least now everybody has a has a
heads up if you're talking about hitting
the road because this is it would be
such a bummer you're all ready to go
you're all packed and then because your
passport isn't ready yikes yikes I know
uh and you know but this is May if you
haven't done it already you may not be
able to travel early July right about
that start the process sooner than later
get honest